Steve Kaufmann today I want to talk
about conversation exchanges language
exchanges via the internet it's
something that is available to us today
that wasn't available when I started
learning languages it's amazing by the
way do you like my Japanese t-shirt I
got that we had a team of old-timers
hockey pirates from Japan visit with us
and we all got a nice t-shirt um yeah I
mean when I think back fifty years ago
and I was studying Chinese the idea that
I could just get on and talk to someone
through some magic computer I mean can
you imagine 50 years ago this was just
inconceivable that you could just do
this and so nowadays there are a number
of sites which offer the opportunity to
connect with teachers some are free some
are in other words just a lack pure
language exchange or conversation
exchange some of them is more of a you
know you you hire a teacher or someone
to speak to I can only talk about my
experience which is limited to I talkie
which I have found very good we have a
similar function at link but I don't
think ours is we don't have as many
tutors as I talked he I don't think in
many ways we do it is well we do
something some parts of it I think we do
better but where I can find a tutor at
link I use a tutor link but otherwise
I'll go to I talk II know the idea that
you can just connect with people
anywhere in the world who speak the
language that you're speaking Wow some
words of caution personally and I said
this before until I have a certain level
in the language I don't enjoy the
language exchange or conversational
conversation exchange because I want to
make sure I understand what the person
is saying that's absolutely number one
even if I can't express myself well I
want to understand where the other
person is saying and be I want to be
able to say something in the language
because it actually is quite stressful
even when we're speaking well it's
it's a more stressful way to communicate
with someone than sitting with them
across a table it is more stressful I
find that it's a little bit more
exhausting if I speak for example and I
should say I have been speaking now I've
started speaking with Ukrainian tutor
twice a week and I still have my Russian
tutor that I speak to and at the end of
an hour I'm kind of exhausted now in
order to speak for an hour you have to
have you have to be at a certain level
very often I'll start at fifteen minutes
or half an hour and then as I progress I
got up to an hour but it is as I say a
little bit stressful now but it's
certainly something to do and I I think
it's even though I'm a proponent of
input based learning and I spend most of
my time and I still do for example with
my Ukrainian even though I speak two
hours a week but I'm constantly reading
reading now on Ukrainian history
listening to ryu crania in history
listening to her Moscow radio so input
is king but the output is necessary and
these conversation exchange language
exchange sites like I taki and what we
have it linked that's a very good way of
getting that output experience and as an
example of how that works I'm going to
follow this up with the video where I
spoke to someone from Russia who
commented on my one of my youtube videos
that he's learning Japanese and could be
talk a bit about learning Japanese so
what follows here is a separate video
it's quite long because it's very
difficult to keep these things short but
we speak in three languages English
Russian and Japanese and we talked about
mostly about learning Japanese the first
I think 1213 minutes are in English then
there's another seven or eight or
however many minutes in Russian and then
we end up in Japanese and what is very
interesting in this video if you have
the patience to follow it is you know
I've been speaking Ukrainian and mostly
listening to Ukrainian and then I had an
hour of Russian with my Russian key a
tutor and this then was followed by
speaking to this denne in Moscow and
even though my Japanese is
than my Russian I couldn't get my brain
out of Russian I really struggled to
switch over to Japanese and it's the
first time I've had that difficulty
normally I can move quite easily maybe
because I just had that hour of Russian
beforehand because I find that the you
know the language exchange via Skype on
the computer is a little more stressful
than just a casual conversation I will
be interested in hearing from you bye
for now
you